What's going on? Alan Dragu here, and in
today's video, I'm going to show you how
to make money without working.
>> What did you say?
>> Specifically, how to scale yourself to
detach the time you put into work to the
money that you make out of that work.
I'm going to give you my exact model
broken down to get your business as
automated as possible, so you can make
as much money as possible by putting in
the least amount of time, so that you
can spend more time with your kids, or
read books, or play golf, or whatever it
is that you want to do. All right, so
let's take a look at my screen right
here. I'm going to walk you through the
scale yourself 1,000 times framework,
okay? And this framework is a four-step
framework, and I'm going to walk you
through the first framework. And that
first framework is going to help us
establish the mindset and the philosophy
to scaling yourself, and it is evergreen
assets. Everything that you make should
be evergreen, means that it should work
more than one time. If you create a
post, if you create a product, if you
create a sequent, whatever you make has
to work over and over and over without
you having to make that thing again.
This is the basic philosophy on how to
scale yourself. It is assets, not
assignments. And I'm going to show you
how to do that as a creator, as a
writer, okay? So, the first thing is
evergreen content. This is the traffic
to your sales. You can't make any money
without traffic, so we have to get
traffic somehow. You can either do that
through organic content, or you could do
that through paid ads. like paid ads
because the minute you turn paid ads off
is the minute you stop making money. So,
now you have to spend money to make
money, but that's not the philosophy
that we're after. The philosophy that
we're after is that we can make
something once, and it will work over
and over and over and over and over
again, so that way we don't have to
continue working or continue spending to
get the result. You with me? Okay,
fantastic. So, evergreen content, these
are the three ways that I like to do
evergreen content. I like to make
YouTube videos just like this one. And
then I take those YouTube videos and I
put them on podcast, right? You can
export the audio and put it on podcast.
And then I transcript these videos and
publish them as an article on my
website. So, let me show you what that
looks like. So, we go back to my YouTube
channel here, right? So, I have a
YouTube channel here. Here's a video
that I recently made, a modern
copywriting full crash course. It's 2
hours long. I made it, recorded it in
here, and this video has been continuing
to grow. I posted it about 3 weeks ago,
and I click this over here, and here's
the beauty behind this video. I took
this video, and this video will work
forever. Meaning this is an evergreen
asset because YouTube is a search
engine. It's why the things that I laid
out a little bit earlier are all
evergreen. YouTube is a search engine.
Podcast is a search engine. People can
search specific topics, find answers to
those topics through audio, and then
consume that content forever and ever
and ever, 5 years, 10 years, 15. So, it
continues to compound. And then your
website is just Google and ChatGPT and
Reddit and all these things pushing to
high-quality websites. So, for example,
that YouTube video that I'm showing you,
this full 2-hour course type thing,
okay. So, you go watch this video, but
guess what? This video is also exported
on a podcast, right? So, you could go to
Apple Podcast, Spotify, and you can go
find all my podcasts with The Copywriter
Club,
and you could go listen to that same
exact video for 2 hours if you want and
do that instead. Or
you can go to my website, right? You
could go to alantragout.com, which
drives Google traffic. So, So, who's
typing like copywriting course or
anything like that, they're going to go
and find my articles, and so you'll see
my articles and you will find how to do
that copywriting masterclass right here,
which is a transcript
of that video that I recorded. So, this
video that I recorded, I was able to put
this into CapCut, and CapCut has a
transcribed feature, which then I used
to turn that into a flywheel of content.
So, I recorded the video, transcribed it
with CapCut, posted it on my website,
and then I also exported the audio from
CapCut and posted that as a podcast. So,
now you create one evergreen asset that
lives forever on YouTube, which is the
second largest search engine in the
world behind Google, and then you also
capitalize on Google because you can get
search traffic that goes to your website
with the transcribed video. By the way,
you can take that transcription, put it
into Claude, and tell Claude to clean up
the transcription, format it like an
article, things like that, very simple.
Then you take that written version of
your video, post it on your website, and
now you have Google traffic, and then
you take the audio version of your video
and export it to podcast. And so, now
you have three evergreen channels
working in your favor for traffic. So,
I'm going to spend 3 to 4 hours making a
video like this, publishing it, editing
it, all that stuff, 3 to 4 hours. And
that 3 to 4 hours is now going to work
for me forever because every time I
publish a video, it's going to continue
to compound, compound, and compound.
Right? Cuz if you go to my channel, you
could go to videos, you can hit popular,
and you could see that I have other
videos, 69,000, 13,000, 10,000, 6.5
thousand, and all of these are
continuing to compound over and over and
over and over, and they lead to the next
evergreen asset that scales yourself a
thousand times. And that evergreen asset
is a bribe opt-in. The last thing that
you want to do is bet on all of these
social media platforms to build your
business. You need to move all of that
traffic into an asset that you own
because you don't own social media. You
don't own YouTube. You don't own
podcast. You don't own WordPress. You
don't own any of those things. So, you
have to move it to an asset that you
actually own so that you can scale
yourself even more. And the way that we
do that is that we take all this
evergreen traffic, right? The YouTube,
the podcast, the website, and we point
them all to the same thing. And the
thing that you need to point them to is
a bribe. You need to bribe them with a
gift to join your email list. So,
anybody who watches your YouTube videos,
your podcast, your websites, anything
like that, bribe them and say, "Hey, if
you like this video, then I have a free
gift for you. I'm going to give you X in
exchange for your email address." Back
to that modern-day copywriting crash
course, right? There are bribes all over
this video. You got the 2-hour crash
course, free AI market research prompts,
101 super sticky viral hook templates.
There's bribes all over this. And the
reason is because I want them to join my
email list. So, check this out. If I
click one of these bribes right here,
it's going to take me to a landing page
just like this, right? How to go from
beginner to paid writer by becoming
dangerously persuasive with copywriting
in just 2 hours. What this is is a
bribe, right? So, you're going to put
your email address in and then something
else is going to happen. Something
magical. Okay, this is where we continue
to scale and automate without extra
time. So, they're going to put that
bribe in and I have a sequence inside of
Kit, okay? So, I use Kit for all of my
emails. This is not sponsored, but I do
have a link down below if you want to
check out Kit. You're more than welcome
to check it out. And I have two
automatic email sequences. I have a
trigger, okay? A visual automation
trigger that when they enter in their
email address, let me show you. So,
here's the trigger for my visual
automation for like my market research
prompts, which is also in here, right? I
have the market research prompts, the
2-hour course. Here's a visual
automation that when they submit this
form, right? When they get into this
form, they automatically start getting
emails. And I've gotten over 1,200 email
subscribers from that one video, okay?
That one video has brought me a ton of
email subscribers. So, they fill out
this lead magnet form, and then they
start going through my email sequence. I
have two emails that go to them
automatically. I've written these one
time, and they're going to do the work.
They're going to continue to scale
forever. I tell them, "Hey, my friend,
here you go. Here's the lead magnet."
They can click it, and it's a this
beautiful lead magnet, right? You click
this, and it's absolutely stunning,
right? It looks like this. They can walk
through the entire thing. It's
absolutely phenomenal, very beautiful,
very well designed. You go in here. I
tell them, "Reply to let me know that
you got the email." That increases your
deliverability, so that way you don't
land in the spam folder. And then I
introduce myself. I tell them, "Hey, not
only are you going to get this one
email, you're actually going to get a
couple more emails from me because I
send emails on a daily basis telling
stories." And I just walk them through.
I introduce myself in this email, so not
only are they getting a free gift from
me, but they're getting to know me
personally so that I can warm up to
them, and they're willing to listen to
more stories from me. All right. So, now
that we've got them on the first email,
we've introduced ourselves, we've
delivered the lead magnet, we've
introduced ourselves, there's something
else that I do automatically because
they haven't bought anything yet. We
need them to buy something
automatically, so that way we don't have
to continue working to make money. And
that's where I introduce my oops email,
okay? So, check this out. After you opt
into this, you actually get another
email from me 3 hours later, and it's
oops, "Hey, I I
one more thing." And this is where I
actually do the sale. This is where I
actually offer something for you to
check this out. So, it says, I forgot.
This is 3 hours later. Hey, while you're
mastering the art of becoming
dangerously persuasive with copywriting.
So, this is congruent to the gift. They
got the modern-day copywriting crash
course thing. And then congruent, I
offer something that they will likely
want to buy based on the problem they
have. If someone is trying to master
copywriting, then they likely have other
problems like client acquisition,
building their business, things like
that. And that is where I make an offer
to join my Copy Creator Club. This is a
school community that I run. And so, I I
entice them with things that will solve
their problems in there. And then I
upsell it with a guarantee. And they can
click this club page. And what it does
is it takes them
to another asset, okay? And this asset
is a sales page. This sales page was
written, ding ding ding, one time,
right? I wrote this sales page one time.
And so now, I've got this working for me
24/7,
right? Because they went in here, they
got my first email, which intro which
gave them the actual bribe, the lead
magnet, the thing they signed up for.
And then I upsold them to say, "Hey, you
may also like this." You You don't have
to upsell school community. You can
upsell a training, a course, a cohort, a
done-for-you service, a low-ticket item,
anything that can help you
solve a problem for the people you're
trying to serve and make money while
solving that problem. But for me, I have
it go to a sales page that works 24/7.
But I take this even further, right? I'm
going to show you this on the thing.
We've now gotten to the welcome sequence
side where I deliver and I offer. I
deliver and I offer. But that leads us
to the last part, which is auto delivery
of your offer. Okay? You now have to
deliver your offer on auto so that you
can continue making money without
putting in more work. So, now people go
to this and they say, "I'm super
interested." They click this and it
takes them over to the school community.
All right? This is where I sell the
school community. There's 114
copywriters and creators in here
building their one-person business
scaling just like about in this video,
right? Typically, it will say join. I've
I'm already in it, right? Obviously, I'm
already in it. And then when they join,
guess what happens? They get more emails
from me on auto though. It's fantastic.
So, it automatically happens. What
happens is they get this one, "Hey,
you're in." And what I do is I tell
them, "Hey, go do this first. Go
download the School app. Check out the
community tab. Introduce yourself." And
then I have a book that they read. "Hey,
read this codex, okay? Read this. Dive
into it. This is going to tell you
everything that you need to know about
your one-person business, but also some
good to knows. Here's some weekly calls
that you get. Update your calendar with
our weekly calls. Here's previous
versions of those calls. Here's some
master classes that you can dive into.
Here's the 30-day action plan, right?
I'm giving them like a
a a pick-your-path type thing. There's a
lot of ways to solve these problems. And
then, oh man, it even gets it gets even
better. When they are in the community
tab, they introduce themselves. They
talk to other people. They can go to the
classroom. They can get coaching calls
to watch, okay? You can watch these
how-to videos. It's all in here. What
problem are you trying to solve? I got
like 50 videos in here based on the
problem that you're trying to solve. You
want to watch a master class on meta ads
or sales pages or whatever it is, right?
There's so much stuff in here that is so
helpful based on the problem they can
solve. Like, if they're like, "Hey, I'm
I'm learning copywriting, okay?" In the
classroom. Well, now copywriting 101 Oh,
perfect, copywriting 101. And they start
just diving into this. So, now there's
just amples of research, there's amples
of all of this stuff. And so, let me
show you from a full-scale picture,
okay? From a full-scale picture, what we
did right here. We made evergreen
content that works for you 24/7, YouTube
to podcast to website. That went to a
bribe opt-in. That is live 24/7. You
could do a PDF, you could do templates,
like I did templates and teaching with a
PDF. You could give away AI prompts.
Hey, in exchange for your email, I'll
give you these AI prompts. That then
triggers an email sequence where you
deliver that gift to someone and then
you make them an offer. That offer then
goes to a sales page where that is live
24/7. That is selling them for you, VSL
sales page, automatically doing the
selling for your offer. And then, from
that offer page, they opt into your
auto-delivery, where you are then going
to email them exactly what they need or
give them access to a course or give
them access to the modules for the
low-ticket or give them access to your
continuity product, your school, your
community. And then, they can dive into
the rabbit hole. So, I could be
sleeping, all this is happening, and
people are just joining, buying your
stuff, and experiencing the product that
you offer without you having to work on
it. And so, you can focus on making
these things really, really good. make a
bribe opt-in once. You can make that
welcome sequence one time. You can
continuously add great stuff in your
community, so that way when people dive
in, they can experience the best parts
of it without you being there. But,
that's it. That is my whole scale
yourself a thousand times model. I hope
you absolutely enjoyed it. If you did,
go ahead and like this video, subscribe
to the channel so I can make more
content like this. And for God's sakes,
bribe into my email. Did you not get the
picture? I've got tons of stuff in the
link in the description below,
copywriting courses, secrets, AI
prompts, all kinds of stuff for you to
bribe and actually go experience this
for yourself. You could see what my
funnel looks like in action. Reply to
those emails, have some fun, go make
your stuff, and I'll see you on the
email list.